deux ukrainiennes macha et ivana démarre
une nouvelle vie dans l'hexagone suite à
la guerre cette mère et sa fille ont
rejoint la france en passant par la
moldavie et lizbeth directrice de la
société de distribution génériques a
recruté les deux femmes malgré la
barrière de la langue l'avantagé c'est
que sur sur une chaîne logistique a
beaucoup devenu on travaille beaucoup
par numéro donc ça leur a permis dès le
début en fait d'être vite intégré évite
efficace
vous emballer les marchandises selon les
factures et les mettons dans une boîte
c'est très simple et facile même si nous
ne connaissons pas le français
nous pouvons faire facilement notre
travail malgré une communication
en ukraine mach a travaillé dans la
restauration et ivana était commercial
leur métier de préparatrice de commandes
est aujourd'hui bien différent les deux
femmes voient ce nouvel emploi basé à
méré comme une opportunité
bien sûr nous avons de la chance nous
sommes ici depuis trois mois nous sommes
venus nous mêmes
ma belle soeur est venu avec nous et son
enfant mais malheureusement elle ne
trouve toujours pas de travail
ici nous avons carte blanche et nous
sommes très reconnaissantes
au sein de la société macha ivana ont
obtenu un cdi une évidence pour la
directrice le problème c'est qu'il ya
une très grande incertitude contre l
avis quant à l'avenir et l'idée c'est
pas de rajouter de l'incertitude à
l'incertitude pour elle bien sûr leur
premier objectif c'est de rentrer en
ukraine mais on sait pas combien de
temps cette guerre va durer et donc nous
on veut leur laisser la possibilité de
rester ici autant de temps qu'elles ont
encore en auront besoin cette expérience
aura permis de ressouder les salariés
autour d'une cause commune grâce à une
application de traduction ils auront
même pu s'initier à une nouvelle langue
vous échanges avec leurs collègues
chacun apprend des mots de la première
sur le français leurs collègues
apprennent après le mémo en ukrainien et
ça se fait dans une ambiance très
collaborative est sympa depuis leur
arrivée en france mme asha ivana ont été
hébergés au sein d'une famille d'accueil
home nuls dans les yvelines
l'objectif des deux femmes est de
rentrer en ukraine dès que le conflit
sera terminé